هي المره السابعه التي يجتمع فيها مجلس
النواب اللبناني منذ نهايه ايلول سبتمبر
من دون تمكني من انتخاب خليفه
اي حركه سياسيه باغلبيه تخولها فرض مرشحها
النائب ومش المعوض
الذي اغتيل عام 89 حصل على 42 صوتا مدعوما
من القوات اللبنانيه بزعامه سمير
الضروريه لتخطي الجوله الاولى
من انصار حزب الله
40 برلمانيون اخرون صوتوا لاسماء خياليه
منها رئيس شيلي السابق سلفادور الذي توفي
عام 73
انسداد سياسيه يعتبر زعيم حزب الله حسن
نصر الله ان نحله هو التوصل الى مرشح
توافقي وينتقد معوض به مقربا من
الامريكيين
لا يوافقوا عليه النائب المعارض فراس
حمدان من حركه الاحتجاج الشعبي تم تحديد
موعد الجلسه القادمه للبرلمان في الاول من
ديسمبر
عام 2016 عندما ضل منصب رئيس الجمهوريه
شاغره من 29 شهرا قبل